The problem with the European Union today
is that they’re trying to dissolve the “nation-state”
and have a Europe of bureaucrats.
That kind of approach is wrong for the United
States domestically.
It’s wrong for the people of Europe.
And there may be plenty of people around the
world that would like to see Europe come apart
because they misunderstand what the nature
of collective defense is.
A “Europe of nations” as Charles de Gaulle
used to put it would suit the United States
just fine.
I think that the current refugee and terrorism
crises in Europe demonstrate more convincingly
than any argument can that European institutions
are simply not sufficient to protect the people
of the continent.
Security in Europe does not depend on the
European Union—
it depends on the NATO alliance.
And NATO has one thing that the European Union
will never have
and that’s the United States.
That’s what people should focus on.
When Britain leaves and becomes a stronger
partner in NATO again, everybody will be better
off.